bon
la yourte a vécu connu des passages
depuis des odeurs qui subsistent
avant toi
oui
mais cette fin de journée chaotique
brusquement mais c'est dans le haut jura
il ya deux saisons galibert j'ai pas
trop dormi
ah non
on chez vous la céramique aux milliards
que mon avis il est midi
ancrée
je suis en vie
dunod
qu'est ce qui a amené pascal a et a
comment dit on va ouvrir un gîte aussi
sympa et bien parce que mon père ayant
des gens qu est l ai dit qu'on va des
gîtes un peu partout ici
et puis dans ses missions africaines de
chance aussi mais c'est un homme ouvert
logique qui avait pas d'eau pas
d'électricité il n'y avait pas de route
qui venaient ici mais pour la piste de
ski et tous étaient là la routine quoi
tiens
c'est pas comme étant derrière m
oui vous le reste les jeux aux enfants
du couple et comme j'étais réveillé
avant 6h ce matin parce qu'on a bien
fêté hier soir avec l'aisance et la
région qui racontait ce qui faisait le
travail le berger et le faire plantier
moniteur de ski et puis tu sais plus
mme ashton un peu une cuillère mais je
comprends fatigué et demi dans son lit
chaud
pour la journée d'aujourd'hui donc la
nouvelle est bonne a priori et pascal
nous accompagner jusqu'au bout de chemin
jusqu'aux montréalais trouve paul c'est
ça voilà la nouvelle qui fait moins
bonne c'est que vous annoncez hier
peut-être qu'on marche le raid - pour
autant on propre à douala un petit peu
plus qu'il y avait un détour qu'il
aurait détourné mais c'est un clown est
reconnaissant à faire de plus tous
le belge en cours du combat la
difficulté étant d'arriver à les
protéger et demi on met les pieds de la
chaux sont tenues à sabrina son livre
elle assure en fait au vif jana des
impôts et qui n'ont en fait pas percé
non c'est juste il faut des protégés là
c'est tout ce temps
où est la au lac de lamoura
qui est un délinquant en altitude on n'a
pas de très nombreux lacs pour autant
quand on descend vers le plateau il y en
a bien d'autres
même une région du jura qu'on appelle la
région des lacs des cascades du hérisson
mais ici plus en altitude on a des lacs
typiquement d'origine de la sierre comme
on dit il faut imaginer que c'est là
qu'ils ont eu des fonctions aussi que
les sommes utilisées par le passé et au
19e siècle qui est des moulins qui ont
pu s'installer près du lac et on se
demande bien comment parce que l'eau et
on va dire stagnante et ne coule pas en
fait pour autant il ya toujours un
exutoire au revoir plusieurs exutoire y
en a donc on aperçoit la battère à la
barrière et il y en a un autre donc tout
à tout à l'eau de loups mais le
principal c'est comme celui qui est ici
donc c'est profond d'une vingtaine de
mètres
il va monter
pères pouvoir entre nous faire une
petite sieste samedi pour gagner encore
un petit peu plus d'énergie
comment
c'est le mont blanc avec les jumelles
vous pourrez voir même les traces qui
monte au sommet le voir
je suis une fille née dans le jura 2
puis depuis mon enfance je connais on va
dire jamais parfaitement mais plutôt
bien le massif du jura sur toute la
partie les trois départements et
montagne notamment l'objectif c'est
vraiment d'arriver à y faire venir des
gens perdent leur montrer qu'on peut y
voir d'un jour à l'eau des choses
complètement différentes ont des
paysages de la flore la faune aussi à
l'occasion était aussi les gens qu'on y
rencontre la vie qu'il existe ce soit
lié aux activités forestières agricoles
épique tourisme aussi parce qu'il ya un
tourisme qui existent sur le jura autour
de la randonnée
j'en ai quand même âge 24 ans semble
donc ça crée forcément des liens on
partage des choses ensemble ou on a plus
d'affinités skate avec que certaines
personnes par rapport aux nouveaux
caractères on se retrouve plus mais non
je pense qu'on est tous bien ensemble et
voilà on passe des bonnes journées non
c'est quoi votre actif chez soi c'est
pour vous reposer mais aussi en interne
elle garde la plus regardée aux
personnages très rigolo au passé l'idée
phare des phrases personnage atypique de
paris du jurassien qui est sûrement
rester toute sa vie dans les chantres
tester marrant il offert latéraux omar
mesa débrouillez vous avez de quoi mais
là je cuisine pas dessus
john positions acheteuses sur manière
juste oui nico tu écoutes mais au milieu
vous servirez
nicolas on y va
le seuil ce cas moi je dirais 80
kilomètres peut-être même pas
ça marche aller cool c'est plus une
balade je dire ça c'est plat et tout ça
et puis après le paysage donc les vaches
et où si tu as tellement milieu on va
dire ses bonheurs
bon ben les filles vous allez nous
emmener en direction de la petite
dernière donc on se trouve ici sur la
carte et je vais vous demander
simplement de suivre le chemin balisé 2d
du jeu c'est simplement de trouver le
chemin ici n'est pas forcément toujours
et d'ylang-ylang l'ère deschamps entre
muret puis les décombres ok eh ben
la grande randonnée c'est une première
pour tout pour moi j'ai en moi une
première surtout jamais là même qui est
un groupe et les anglais assurent un
chemin une première
mais fanny bienvenus ça me fait tout ça
vous ne captez quoi j'ai vu que c'était
que surtout pas qu'elles fassent leur
propre expérience
surtout ne pas intervenir sans arrêt
parce que bon quand on cherche sa route
puis que on a 36 personnes
donc si on a un avis éclairé on peut on
peut l'écouter ne souvent quand
personnes qui interviennent en plus tu
me prends les quais que ce soit elle qui
décide et qui qui se passe leur
expérience
under
des surfeurs normalement sensibilité
nous oppose la question
le sont pas
la chaleur a fait a fait son effet j'ai
beaucoup plus peiné dans la deuxième
partie
certains des camarades mais avec la
chaleur plus quand même eu de quelques
belles montées et ont surtout en dur et
fort longues heures plus tôt donc là le
pied comme on fait tout pour eux les
cuisses commence à chauffer et puis le
poids du sac plus la chaleur ça
commençait à devenir un peu difficile la
petit à petit on va plutôt entrer dans
une zone de près bois la forêt va se
rapprocher peu à l'origine c'était un
honneur clair à semble-t-il la forêt de
la phrase est donc à partir du xvième
siècle il est devenu la forêt du
massacre
pour quelles raisons votre avis que
s'est il passé
la guerre ou l'abattage des arbres
peut-être on a massacré qui ou quoi d
armor à la forêt non justement on n'a
pas massacré des arbres sort et et des
arbres finalement ça a été pas plus mal
effectivement donc en 535 en fait ici il
ya eu une bataille qui s'est déroulée
entre le col de la faucille et ici donc
les troupes de françois 1er
ce sont obligés de se replier et
notamment dans la forêt ici où il
semblerait qu'ils aient été assez
largement exécutés massacres et est
depuis cette époque ont attaqué la forêt
du massacre
c'est triste mais c'est comme ça donc
c'est un vrai massage j'aimerais
profiter d'occasions qu'on soit ici ce
qu'on s'est pas arrêté à un endroit non
plus intéressant au niveau au flanc
c'est qu'on a une magnifique fleur
derrière nous déjà connu pinatel qui
fait partie des plantes protégées aussi
est plus toxique qu'on puisse rencontrer
chez nous lafleur et caractéristiques
mais la part la couleur également qu'il
propre à laconique n'appelle non si les
feuilles et feuilles aconit sont
également on y reconnaît également de
très facilement mais là sont très très
belle vie est un super pro il connaît
toutes les plantes tu sais bien les
expliquer il connaît bien
tout s'est passé ce qui s'est passé dans
la forêt du massacre était bien un nom
est bien expliqué non
c'est ce qu'on attend d'un guide de
moyenne montagne un kilt kwal
connaissent à la fois la montagne et
puis surtout le l'environnement dans
lequel il vit c'est bien par là c'est
bien par là
voilà on approche de ces fameux et
qu'ici à muter jusqu'à mi hauteur on va
dire un épicier à tout à fait
traditionnelle et tout tout d'un coup
donc qui devient quelqu'un à part d'être
si près on ne peut piller on va
peut-être guère plus tôt si près donc
mais sachant que c'est le même type de
d'aiguilhe d'orange contre vous dessus
mais avec cette forme
coolio meneur il faudrait quoi il
faudrait qu'on hurle de joie on le
ferait de matane bonheur auquel là on
n'a qu'une envie c'est de nous laver de
poser la tente de nous reposer mois
pleins qc pas d'accord non machette je
suis pas d'accord avec la manière est
normalement mercredi à sa manière ceci
dit demi heure de marche
ceci dit le lépi serre et atterrissant
non
une bougie des allumettes
de quoi faire où il ya un deuxième
couteau
ouais
on est dans le flou le plus artistique
et ça sur le moral des troupes
c'est mortel quand est ce que mange
quand est-ce qu'on s'arrête quand est ce
qu'on peut se laver et wes condor ça
c'est primaire pour tout le monde
visiblement ça n'est pas pris en compte
ne parle pas c'est tu pleureras situe à
parler au nom du groupe qui demande à
chacun son avis et éventuellement voilà
moi je ne suis pas d'accord
on savait que c'était une aventure
voulait surtout dire que j'étais pas
d'accord
maintenant voilà ne parle pas en amont
voilà c'est pourquoi
fatiha plus animaux que prévu que les
cochons et pour l'équipe c'est sympa ça
mon petit coin est en plein dedans
on voit quelque chose qu'on adore encore
du bruit amicaux pirlo s'est couché une
cape et humide et 3 c'est un peu
compliqué pour se rendormir
globalement ça a été mais pour m
on va faire une montée sur un kilomètre
ton cd chemin très difficile fins et des
anciens chemins qui avait autrefois qui
permettait aux roulier de se déplacer et
transportés soit le bois les
marchandises
fatou transports
tango terre c'était appartenait à
l'hospice
si une partie de la forêt du massacre
donc on devrait sourire une borne sous
une borne dans la troisième fois est
limité de la zone
voilà donc vous voulez la borne à un peu
beauf fois
mais derrière on s'entraîne on voit les
chevaux qui travaillent qui disent
qu'ils prennent de la vitesse dans les
montées et qui qui subit sans fin qui
fait la charia doit être très légère
donc une impressionnante c'est une belle
vue de l'activité de 6,2 du jura
jusque là les crackers
comment ne pas aimer quoi c
c'est fantastique quand même